les partis politiques pierrette au parti
socialiste françoise et à l'ump a nié
dans un parti d'extrême gauche et franck
est au front national
ils sont donc tous membres d'un parti
politique ça veut dire qu'ils ont décidé
de rejoindre d'autres gens qui pensent
comme eux et défendent la même vision de
la société
c'est dans les années 1870 à la
naissance de la troisième république que
sont vraiment né les partis politiques
tels qu'on les conçoit aujourd'hui avant
les ouvriers se réunissaient dans des
organisations ouvrières les paysans
défendez leur intérêt comme les nobles
ou les bourgeois chacun de leur côté et
les mandats électifs se disputer entre
personnalités influentes et notables
locaux en fonction de leur
respectabilité
aujourd'hui pierre françoise annie et
franck réfléchissent avec leurs amis ou
leurs camarades de parti à tous les
aspects de la vie en commun l'économie
l'éducation la famille l'immigration la
politique étrangère la sécurité ce sont
donc les partis politiques qui sont
chargés d'organiser et d'exprimer la
diversité de la volonté populaire
ils doivent recourrir les besoins les
volontés les aspirations de la
population pour les transformer en
proposition concrète
ces propositions sont élaborés par les
responsables des partis par les
militants parfois aussi et sont
rassemblés dans des programmes lors des
différentes élections
d'ailleurs la constitution de la vème
république je vous en parle dans un
autre épisode le dit dans son article 4
les partis politiques concourent à
l'expression du suffrage
le second rôle des partis politiques
c'est d'organiser la sélection des
candidats que chacun d'entre eux
présentera aux différentes élections
ça peut se faire de manière démocratique
par le vote des militants
ou alors c'est le chef du parti et son
entourage proche qui décident
autoritairement pour tout le monde
ces dernières années les partis
politiques n'étaient plus très populaire
il y avait de moins en moins de
militants en leur sein une grande partie
de la population estime qu'ils sont
devenus des repères d'ambitieux qui
vivent dans leur monde et qui veulent
simplement accéder au pouvoir
pour remédier à cette défiance les
partis politiques ont décidé de s'ouvrir
et organise maintenant des élections
primaires ouvertes à tout le monde pour
désigner leurs candidats aux élections
parce que les partis politiques sont
utiles à la démocratie ils sont financés
par l'état proportionnellement à leurs
résultats aux élections mais cela ne
suffit pas et les militants sont mises à
contribution
pierre françoise annie et franck et
leurs amis militants sont pour la
plupart des passionnés qui donnent
beaucoup de leur temps pour convaincre
leurs concitoyens et faire vivre la
démocratie
certains sont surtout ambitieux et rêve
d'atteindre le pouvoir parfois ils
peuvent être les deux c'est généralement
cela que l'on retrouve député maire
ministre et bien sûr président de la
république